the Ferrari is exactly the same in the
human context I say the Peacocks tail is
in the peacock hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller
with reason TV
we're here with GAD sod holds the
Concordia University Research Chair in
evolutionary behavioral sciences and
Darwinian consumption and is the author
of the book the consuming instinct what
juicy burgers Ferraris pornography and
gift-giving reveal about human nature
thank you for joining us today thank you
for having me it's pleasure to be here
in basic terms the books about
evolutionary psychology and its
relationship to consumerism
what does evolutionary psychology have
to say about what we spend our money on
there are a myriad of consumer phenomena
that happen in exactly the same way
around the world
so they transcend culture they transcend
time period and they do that precisely
because they are part of a common
biological heritage and so what I try to
do is look for these universals in the
consumer arena and then argue that they
are rooted in our shared biological
heritage Ferraris pornography juicy
burgers and gift-giving what is the
significance of those four things why
did you choose that I stupid that's a
great question so basically I'm trying
to demonstrate that there are four key
Darwinian modules or meta drives that
drive much of our consumer patterns when
it comes to juicy burgers this refers to
the survival module so most animals have
to face two recurring problems making
sure they don't become somebody's dinner
and making sure that they find dinner
and so our evolved gustatory preferences
are exactly an adaptation to that it's
not difficult for us to then succumb to
the temptation of the Burger King and
the McDonald's because they are offering
products that are fully congruent with
our taste buds when it comes to
pornography or Ferraris that refers to
the mating module so let's take for
example the Ferrari
well I argue that the Ferrari is exactly
the same in the human context as say the
Peacocks tail is in the peacock so the
peacock shows its tail and the females
will choose that Mayor who has the most
iridescent colors the biggest tail the
most symmetric patterns and the Ferrari
is effectively signaling similar things
but in the human context we did a study
a few years ago with one of my
former graduate students where we
brought people into the lab men and we
had them either drive a fancy Porsche or
a beaten-up old sedan at the end of each
of these driving conditions we would
collect salivary assays to measure their
fluctuating levels of testosterone and
as you might expect you put a young male
in a Porsche and his testosterone shoots
through the roof because that and the
chronological mechanism is akin to
saying hey I just I was just imbued with
a with a social win we know in many
social species when two males fight the
winner has a rise in testosterone the
loser has a drop in testosterone and
what's an example of that among women
how do women's behaviors as consumers
change as a function of their menstrual
cycles and so I did a study recently
with one of my doctoral students where
we tracked 435 contiguous days so that
we covered the full menstrual cycle
every imaginable consumer Tory behavior
that a woman engages in across those 35
days when it comes to food women engage
in a lot more food related behaviors and
the luteal stage of their so on the non
fertile stage of their menstrual cycle
and the fertile stage of their menstrual
cycle they engage in a lot more
beautification related things so they're
engaging in sexual signaling so how
provocatively they dress whether they
wear high heels with how they wear their
hair how much skin they show ends up to
be perfectly correlated to whether or
not they are in the fertile phase so
here's two examples testosterone one
case in the menstrual cycle in one case
that demonstrates how our hormones
affect our behaviors as consumers so
you're saying that our consumption is
driven by these Darwinian mechanisms a
lot of regulation now assumes we have
not enough information or we have bad
information we need to have the calories
listed at McDonald's or we need to have
warnings listed on cigarette packages
but you seem to be saying it's not that
the information is bad it's that we have
these natural drives within us that's
exactly right so if you're coming from
the standard social marketing
perspective consumers engage in bad
behaviors or behaviors that have
dilatory consequences because they don't
have the right information teach them
and they will behave better but we know
for a fact that
it's not right when it comes to smoking
for young males telling them that they
might develop lung cancer it doesn't
work very well telling them that they
stand the risk of becoming impotent at a
very young age actually does affect
their behavior and it doesn't take much
of a biologist to understand that
telling a young male that he might be
impotent and not be able to perform is
an effective you know communication
strategy so we can finally kind of scrap
this idea that it's the evil genius ad
executives or media messages or the
capitalist system making us want all
these things that we don't need the
advertisers are effective to the extent
that they provide you with messages that
are congruent with your involved human
nature right so they're not providing
you with wants and needs that are
completely inconsistent with your human
nature right so if you if I give you a
budget and unlimited budget to sell raw
broccoli it probably wouldn't work but
if I give you a very small budget to
sell fatty juicy burgers well it's not
it's not a difficult sell because it is
consistent with what I want right so
Harlequin romance is able to sell
romance novels to women around the world
precisely because it contains a certain
narrative that appeals to women's
evolved sexual fantasies and so again
advertisers are not these evil geniuses
as you said they are providing us with
messages that ultimately have to speak
to our human nature but to reduce every
human choice down to a kind of Darwinian
imperative you know needing to pass on
our genes to the next generation aren't
we able to kind of rationally overcome
that now that we have an evolved mine
that no longer needs to be looked at as
this sort of stone age brain right
evolution psychology doesn't argue that
we're deterministically fatalistic and
our behaviors because everything is an
interaction between your genes and the
environment and your unique upbringing
and so on so certainly the idea of
biological determinism is not a
relevance evolution psychology that said
despite the fact that we have this
knowledge it is an alluring trap to fall
into and that's why in many cases moral
philosophers and theologians have tried
to warn us against the seven deadly sins
precisely because they're difficult to
extricate ourselves from biological
evolution it's
basically indisputable at this point I
mean we have fossil records we've
verified it in laboratories we've done
artificial selection breeding when it
comes to evolutionary psychology do we
have that same kind of evidence how do
you convince us that it's a science and
not you're coming up with these creative
stories to kind of fit your premise I
mean that's a great question because
that's that's one that you constantly
hear as an evolutionary scientist oh
you're just coming up with just so
storytelling interestingly though when
evolutionary biologists come up with
similar hypotheses for every other known
species they're valid scientific
hypotheses but if somehow you engage in
the exact same scientific method when it
comes to the human mind or well you're
just engaging in just so storytelling
and the reality is that the data that
typically evolution psychologists
collect to support or to test one of
their hypotheses is actually
extraordinarily more meaty if you'd like
than the standard behavioral sciences in
the book you do actually mention there
is a sort of cultural fossil that
evolutionary psychologists can look to
exactly so the human mind doesn't
fossilize but what does fossilize I
argue are the cultural products that are
created by human minds so if we take
song lyrics troubadours in the Middle
Ages hip hop songs today hindi songs or
earthly songs are all going to have
roughly the same themes that are covered
despite otherwise radically different
musical genres and those themes are well
in the case of say song lyrics a
universal mating preferences so what are
the things that men typically sing about
and what are the things that women's
typically sing about turn out to be
extraordinarily similar across otherwise
unbelievably disparate musical John's
men will sing about the woman's beauty
about specific body parts I like big
butts I can I like big butts and I
cannot lie sir mix-a-lot I believe and
women will typically denigrate men who
for example are low social status Bills
Bills Bills no scrubs all of that
there's endless other sounds that's
basically say look if you're low status
if you're unemployed if you if you don't
have ambition don't approach me I'm not
interested you do a lot of
comparing what men in general do and
women in general the stereotype is that
it would be the religious right
attacking evolutionary scientists but it
seems like you're getting it from
left-right all over the puzzle director
you're exactly right there are endless
ideological camps that hate evolutionary
psychology for no reason that has to do
with science but everything to do with
it being perceived as an attack on their
pet you know ideological theory so if I
am a feminist I reject innate sex
differences if I'm a social
constructivist I reject the possibility
that we have innate blueprints in our
brain when we're born and so on and so
forth but they're driven by ideology not
by science
God said thank you very much for joining
us for that my pleasure for reason TV
I'm Zack Weiss moment
[Music]